foreign
[Music]
cloud data flow jobs not exactly well
flowing in this video you'll learn how
to troubleshoot and resolve slow and
stuck jobs to get back to going with the
flow to begin let's look at how to
identify if the data flow job is indeed
slow or stuck if your pipeline runs
slowly or runs for a long time without
reporting results has increased data
Watermark that is increased data
freshness or system latency is not
consuming input then it indicates that
the data flow job is slow or stuck to
troubleshoot this issue analyze the logs
in Cloud logging to determine if there
are any errors that may be causing the
jobs to be stuck or become slow for this
use this filter by replacing the data
flow job ID with your data flow job ID
a data flow job can be slow or stuck due
to multiple causes today I will show you
how to identify a few common causes for
the stuck slow jobs and resolve them
let's start with the first one If You
observe the message something like this
in the logs then it indicates that the
workers are taking a long time to
process the code
to investigate further examine the stack
Trace that follows this message and
identify the package or classes from the
method which is stuck if the package and
classes are owned by you then you will
need to debug further to determine the
cause of this issue if they are part of
Google beam code then reach out to
Google Cloud support team for further
assistance
If You observe one of these errors in
the logs then it indicates that you are
writing files with insufficient shards
it means that the writing threads are
unable to keep up with the demand to fix
this issue specify a higher number of
shards by using the API with Nam shards
and on your right files transform
ensure the value of n is at least equal
to the max worker pool size
enable auto sharding if your thing
supports it
use of hotkeys is another common reason
for slowness in data flow jobs data flow
has the capability to identify critical
hotkey issues automatically you can
determine if hotkeys are used by using
the following query in log Explorer if
hotkeys are detected then you will see
an error as shown here
hotkeys contains elements that can
negatively affect the pipeline
performance these Keys limit the ability
of data flow to process elements in
parallel thus increasing the execution
time
to resolve this issue do the following
re-key your data apply Padu transform so
that it generates new key value pairs
for Java and python jobs use the
appropriate transforms shown here
enable data flow Shuffle this operation
partitions and groups data by key in a
scalable efficient fault tolerant manner
this feature available for batch
pipelines only moves the shuffle
operation out of the worker VMS and into
the data flow service backend
refer to the links to know more about
these and how to apply each of these
Solutions
data flow jobs can get stuck or run slow
if there are out of memory or om errors
use this filter in the log Explorer to
find out if the data flow job is
experiencing om errors
if your worker has failed with om then
you will see an error like this
to mitigate this issue increase the
worker memory use a machine type with
larger memory
for example if your workers are on N1
standard 4 then use N1 heimm M4 if you
are already using a high mem machine
then use a high-mem machine type with
additional CPU and RAM
decrease the parallelism of processing
using the pipeline option number of
worker harness threads for streaming
pipelines the default number used is
300. for batch it is the number of
processors on the worker note that
decreasing the parallelism may impact
the performance of the pipeline as CPUs
may be underutilized if processing is
blocked on reading state
for this reason we recommend using a
machine type with larger memory
configure the data flow workers to start
only one containerized python process
regardless of the worker vcpu count
using the pipeline option shown here
enable data flow Prime on the data flow
jobs pipelines using data flow Prime
benefit from automated and optimized
Resource Management reduced operational
costs and improved diagnostic
capabilities
more information can be found here on
this link
for more information about
troubleshooting slow or stuck jobs check
out the following documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]